well you know maybe it's time for the
whole show to
[Applause]
[Music]
regenerate
[Music]
i should have grabbed some sunglasses
but i'm too dang lazy okay
folks this um it's funny this is a topic
that was actually spurred on
by uh some stuff that i saw on twitter
a little while back at the time that
this will actually be released
some people making a case for why they
think it might
be time to reboot doctor who
i'm gonna tip my hand up front and say
uh no no we shouldn't
it should not ever be necessary to but
here's the thing i actually thought
through all the reasons why
what reasons are there to reboot
something
why do those reasons apply or not apply
to doctor who
is what we lose more than what we would
gain by rebooting
so having gone through all the thought
of that
might as well squeeze a video out of it
by sharing those thoughts with you
so let's start with what are the reasons
why you would normally
look to reboot a property well there are
a few
one is if it has reached some kind of
natural conclusion that doesn't
allow for continuations that is
obviously not the case with doctor who
unless something
really insane happens uh in the upcoming
years
it's a show that could potentially just
go on forever
so that doesn't apply another reason
would be
if your key performers are aging out of
the property
the only way to keep it going is to just
hit the reset button
also doesn't apply to doctor who because
of the mechanism of regeneration
in addition to that sometimes you
reboot because it has been so long
since the last time anyone has touched
this property that
you're better off just starting over
rather than trying to in some way
continue it
which obviously doesn't apply to doctor
who because
it's currently running and even if
we were to try and apply that logic even
if it went off air
and was off air for a while
it's come back from that before
like we take it for granted at this
point
that russell t davies when he brought
back doctor who in 2005
did it as a continuation of the original
show he didn't have to do that
he could have rebooted it from scratch
there were some people even inquiring
that of him wondering like
oh are you going to change it so it's
not a police box you're gonna make it a
red phone box you know you're gonna
change this you're gonna change that
you're gonna
start over like he could have done a
clean break
it was the perfect opportunity to do it
to be honest
at that point i've been off the air for
so long that
you're introducing it to a whole new
generation of fans anyway
is there a point in tying you back to
the old stuff wouldn't it be cleaner to
reboot yeah probably
probably but he didn't and uh i think
that's worth remembering
but what are some other reasons to
reboot
because there are a few others sometimes
continuity gets so tangled and muddled
that it becomes distancing and
off-putting
for new people to come in and you have
audience stagnation
that's the kind of thing that happens
with comic books all the time
and that is about the one that i think
might have some validity
and actually apply to something like
doctor who
because let's be honest the show has
been going for a while and i don't mean
like the total
50 plus years i forget what we're two
years away from the 60th now
i'm not talking about that i'm talking
about just the revive series
we're going to be getting series 13 next
and at this point
continuity has gotten more
convoluted and was some of the stuff i
saw brought up on the twitter thread
like
is gallifrey around or not is the doctor
a time lord
or not what planet are the cybermen from
like these sorts of things that the fact
that there are multiple answers to these
and many other questions
would seem to indicate continuity has
gotten so tangled
that maybe it's time to just get a clean
slate
i still don't think that would justify a
reboot though and here's why
part of the beauty of a show like doctor
who
that makes it unique when compared to
other things with sprawling continuity
like comic book universes
and this is true in general but it's
doubly true of doctor who
continuity is only as big a problem as
you make it
because here's the thing something like
a comic book universe
something like to pick one of my
favorites spider-man
over the years things have gotten more
complicated
he has aged gradually but the ways in
which his
foes die and then they come back and
he's always operating in new york city
and the heroes he knows and the heroes
who like him
and the ones who don't everything gets
intermixed and entangled and
it's very tricky to unravel that and it
can be intimidating
for new people to come in
but doctor who doesn't have the same
kind of limitations that someone like
spider-man does
spider-man is stuck on earth
in this world in the marvel universe and
all the complexities that come with it
doctor who is not tethered to
anything doctor who
can take place anywhere in
time or space and do
anything and the fact that the
continuity is
jumbled which let's be clear it's always
been
doesn't matter unless the showrunner is
drawing attention to it
if whoever takes over after chibnall is
of the opinion
that the continuity is too convoluted
you don't have to reboot it
to fix that all you have to do is send
the doctor off on new adventures
and not deal with the continuity messes
like honestly the whole brain of morbius
thing
which appears to have been part of what
inspired chris chibnall to do the
timeless child thing
the brain of morbius and the fact that
we got images of people
who were not any of the known doctors
and the show was implying that these
were previous incarnations
of the doctor that happened in what the
70s
80s i can't remember but it hadn't been
a problem
because nobody had brought it up again
since then and we all just moved on
it didn't bog the show down until
somebody decided to make a deal out of
it
it's an issue now because
chibnall's made a thing of it but it's
only as big a deal as you make it
so any showrunner has the ability to
simplify it
just by ignoring that stuff and sending
the doctor off on new adventures
oddly enough chipnel actually kind of
did this
with series 11 which didn't really have
much of an ongoing story
didn't have any recurring characters
come in recurring villains
did almost no direct tie-ins to the
continuity
and was much more self-contained as a
whole and on an episode by episode basis
yet it also didn't while it gave a boost
to the ratings uh certainly versus
series 10
it wasn't sustained in the way i think
a lot of people had hoped and it
probably wasn't even as big a boost as
some had wanted
but here's the thing and this is where
i'm going to
try and meet the idea of rebooting the
show halfway
there may come a time
when it is to doctor whose benefit
to take a break three five
to be gone long enough for us to miss it
so i'm not talking about the fact that
like
oh we haven't had a proper series in a
while we've just had a couple special
that's happened before
that's not what i'm talking about we may
reach a point where
we genuinely need a chance to miss the
show
but even more important than that there
is
there is a reason i brought up comic
books in relation to all this not just
as a comparison
there is something that comic books do
that is a cheap trick but it works
you restart the numbering and by that i
mean
series 11 may have been more
approachable
new doctor stand alone stuff no real
callbacks
but it still says series 11.
people are still going to come in
knowing that there's 10 years worth of
stuff prior to that
before even dealing with classic who
it can still be intimidating so if
hypothetically if chibnall's done after
series 13
somebody new comes in for series 14
doesn't deal with all the continuity
messes that might still be sitting
around
we get a new doctor it's a clean slate
start
but if it's still called series 14
i think it's going to be hard to either
entice people who have fallen off the
show to come back
or to bring new people in because a
number that high
is intimidating and for people who have
fallen off the show for whatever reason
numbering it and continuing the
numbering means you're still tying it to
the thing that they lost interest in
it is very common in comic books well
reboots are common in comic books bit
more of a dc thing than a marvel thing
but reboots full continuity reboots do
happen but you know what's way more
common than that
renumbering starting a new series
same character not even breaking
continuity
and detaching from what had gone on
before but starting with a new
number one issue and like let's be
honest
this is a technique that the comics
industry abuses
but they abuse it because it works
number one issues always sell more
and part of the purpose beyond just the
mercenary sales attitude of it
but part of the purpose of starting from
number one
is to make it less intimidating for
people to get started
because if you see issue 98
even if it looks good party is going to
be going oh
i don't know issue one
screams start here
taking a break and starting again not
with an
actual continuity reboot
just by calling it doctor who series
one
that combined with like i said avoiding
some of the continuity quagmires much
like
russell d russell t davis did in the
2005 startup of the modern era of doctor
who
there were continuity things in there
but they were nods they were small
things they were things that still
played and made sense even if you did
not
know any of the details of all of the
classic
decades of doctor who taking that
approach
after a pause not to like we should did
not a hiatus as long as we got between
classic and
like please no i love this show too much
but
we and and also i should say i'm not
entirely sure we're at this point yet
however there may come a point where a
break is a good idea and
when the show comes back following a
break
start with number one again but don't
reset continuity
you don't have to doctor who has so many
things built into it
that means it never needs to be rebooted
and if something's a problem
ignore it deal with something else
oh we have we've decided to completely
wipe out
you know this planet and these species
and the daleks are
really dead forever this time and
they're not coming back again
we're serious okay well have the doctor
land at an earlier point in the timeline
when the daleks are still around look at
that new dalek story
this show has so many awesome creative
ways to work around
stagnation that rebooting
seems to me to misunderstand what the
show
has and that's ignoring also the fact
that
when you reboot something
you're not just expecting a reset of the
continuity and then to tell the same
story
you're expecting things to change
there's a reason that after the sam
raimi spider-man
the amazing spider-man looked like this
and then after that the new spider-man
for the mcu
looked like this if you're going to
justify a reboot
you have to make core fundamental
changes because otherwise
why not just a continuation if you truly
rebooted it
you would kind of have to change
major aspects of
the concept the mood the tone or the
aesthetic
of the show you'd have to change some of
the iconography
you'd have to change things in a way
that would explain
why you couldn't just be continuing this
within the same continuity you want to
see how this can bite you in the butt
one of the major issues certainly one of
the ones that i had
with oh god i can't believe i'm going to
bring this up
ghostbusters 2016.
i'm sorry but one of the issues
with that was the fact that there was
absolutely no reason that that story
could not have happened
in continuity with the originals there
was zero reason
why that could not be a new group of
ghostbusters
picking up on the work of ghostbusters
who had gone out of business and were
out of the game for ages
or were working in a different city or
something else
there was nothing about that
story and that film that said oh
we definitely can't do this in the same
continuity because the core concept
the major aesthetics the all the key
factors
exactly the same there was no need to
hit a reset button
and people got annoyed they also got
annoyed for very
stupid and oftentimes sexist reasons and
a bunch of other
nonsense but that was certainly an issue
i had and it was one that a lot of
people had
if you're going to reboot you need to
make some substantive changes
and do you really want that
i understand that maybe you want a new
show runner maybe you want a new doctor
maybe you want it to stop
focusing on certain aspects of the
continuity all those things can be
accomplished
without rebooting there is no reason to
ever reboot the doctor who continuity as
far as i'm concerned
there you go what are your thoughts
about this
can should whatever doctor who reboot
yay
nay whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments
let's talk about it i have a patreon
which is how i pay my bills and keeps
this whole operation up and running i
don't have a sponsor this time
but if you like these earrings they are
made by paper cranes and pride on
etsy these specific ones these gender
fluid tardis
this design is not on the store these
were custom but they have a ton
of great pieces jewelry things like that
in various pride colors go check them
out they're worth your time
good folks so you've got my patreon to
check out you've got that store to check
out but even beyond that like share
subscribe
all that actually does help and i
appreciate it
but you also don't have to because at
the end of the day my friends
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye